first off let's start with a question
could the war in Ukraine cause a famine
in Africa
[Music]
I know what many of you are thinking
Russia and Ukraine are over here on the
Eastern edge of Europe while the
countries of Africa are way down here on
this large landmass but the reality
visual politic viewers is that the war
has turned the world upside down we've
already told you in a lot of videos how
it has caused chaos in the energy
markets however that's not the only
Consequence the war in Ukraine is also
putting another very important Market
the agricultural Market on the ropes
think about it it's very difficult to
live without oil without gas or with the
price of these hydrocarbons skyrocketing
but living without wheat or corn is not
easy either in fact for millions and
millions of people the lack of these
Foods could mean the difference between
eating or going hungry and you'll
probably say okay but what a Russia and
Ukraine have to do with all of this well
more than you might think basically
because we are talking about two of the
largest agricultural producers in the
world I'm sure many of you who are
watching us from Europe from the United
States or even from Latin America have
noticed that food prices have gone up a
lot during the last year Well you you
already know what one of the main
reasons is it certainly has been tough
but fortunately in general in most parts
of the world we are not starving however
there is one part of the world where the
same cannot be said sub-Saharan Africa
we have told you many times here on
visualpolitik how in the world and
particularly in sub-Saharan Africa so
much progress has been made in recent
years that for many people famines were
doomed to be nothing more than bad
chapters in the history books and indeed
famine did seem to be on the road to
Extinction the Russian and Ukrainian
agricultural sectors have been key
players in this to give you an idea
Ukraine produces enough food for 400
million people every year many of them
in sub-Saharan Africa but now the war
has complicated Everything Green exports
from Ukraine and Russia are no longer as
large and frequent as they were before
Putin launched his troops on his
neighboring country and naturally this
has caused tensions in agricultural
markets to Skyrocket and not just
because Ukrainian Black Sea ports are
constantly targeted by Russia or because
fighting has limited Ukraine's
production but because even sanctions on
Russia now make its exports much more
difficult and more expensive the result
the likelihood of an uncontrolled food
crisis has not been this High since the
1980s so the question is what
initiatives are being promoted to avoid
a catastrophic famine why were Russia
and Ukraine selling so much wheat to
Africa and two other questions that may
support you even more what is Turkey's
role of all of this in the story could
turkey succeed in preventing a worldwide
famine today we're going to answer all
of these questions but first you know
what's coming let's look at some history
[Music]
technology production and hard work
if you are faithful followers of
visualpolitik you will remember that one
of the things we have repeated Ad
nauseam on this channel is the number of
people suffering from poverty and going
hungry has been plummeting around the
world over the last few decades so far
this Century extreme hunger has ceased
to be commonplace and that is mainly due
to one reason technological advances and
remember that if I were to ask you which
economic sector has developed the most
in recent decades I'm pretty sure most
of you would automatically think of
industry or I.T or something like that
am I wrong I'm pretty sure I'm not and
in a way you are right but you know what
the evolution of the Agricultural sector
is no less impressive to give you an
idea at the beginning of the 20th
century in Europe or the United States
we could still find images like this one
however today the fields of the most
developed countries increasingly
resemble this exactly it is increasingly
common to see how driverless tractors
irrigation robots drones and many other
technological advances allow us to
produce much more food every year not to
mention genetically modified foods the
truth is that in the coming decades we
may see an enormous growth growth in
food production a leap that we already
experienced a few decades ago between
the 1960s and the 1980s there was a 180
degree turnaround in agricultural
markets of course I am talking about the
so-called Green Revolution
the Green Revolution was nothing more
than a gigantic increase in agricultural
productivity on a global scale it began
in Mexico and the United States at the
end of the 1950s with the wheat
Revolution and gradually spread
throughout the world the increase in
productivity came about thanks to the
use of new technologies the planting of
cereals resistant to the most extreme
climates and pests and the use of
synthetic fertilizers and pesticides as
a result countries in Latin America and
throughout Asia such as Mexico Pakistan
and India were able to multiply their
production
[Music]
another well-known case was that of
China a country where the Green
Revolution along with the pro market
reforms implemented by Deng Xiaoping
succeeded in reducing famine levels to
Historic lows we could say that the
Green Revolution left even the most
faithful malthusian trembling since it
clearly proved that the increase in
production is fully compatible with the
increase in population and that world
hunger might just be eradicated and not
only that it also confirmed another
Trend that is now more than evident that
higher production does not mean more
people working in agriculture in fact as
you can see fewer and fewer people are
working in the sector and at the same
time production is increasing however
wait a moment because not all of the
process was quite so successful
sub-Saharan Africa was the only region
of the world that could not successfully
join the Green Revolution why
well actually for several reasons the
first and perhaps most important is that
while the rest of the countries were
already independent during the Green
Revolution many of the sub-Saharan
African countries were still struggling
to free themselves and when they
succeeded internal power struggles and
corrupt governments began to flourish
making it virtually impossible to
develop infrastructure projects that
would allow production to be increased
and then transported from one place to
another of course investment in
Agricultural Development needs
sufficient infrastructure to be able to
quickly export their production that's
not all though for example the same lack
of infrastructure is also one of the
reasons why fertilizer use is so low in
the region because Transportation costs
are much higher and if we add to all
this the extreme climatic conditions in
marinate areas of sub-Saharan Africa
then we have the perfect cocktail to
explain the underdevelopment of the
sector in the region this is precisely
what explains to a large extent why
subsistence agriculture is still the
order of the day here and why many of
the countries in the region have to
import so much food and as the
population keeps growing then the
problem is clear the demand for food
imports is increasing and of course
faced with such a scenario the Ukrainian
War has said that ticking Time Bomb off
visual politic viewers this is precisely
the number one reason why the Ukrainian
War has become such a huge nightmare for
the Forgotten continent check this out
[Music]
Financial Innovation against famine
the anti-globalization activists at the
beginning of the 21st century we had
many people saying things like Financial
globalization was going to completely
destroy the third world and that the
difference between rich and poor
countries would increase
catastrophically well nothing could
actually be further from the truth in
this video we have already told you how
technological Evolution has multiplied
agricultural production to the point of
drastically reducing famines around the
world but what we have not yet told you
is how Financial Innovations have also
helped to end Hunger in the world we are
talking specifically about the so-called
agricultural Futures market and you may
be wondering what the hell is an
agricultural future Market well
basically they are markets where you can
buy and sell very easily agricultural
products such as wheat or corn without
having to move them all the time they
are instruments that allow you to
guarantee your food supply in the future
this is why they are called futures of
course these markets are not strictly
new far from it they have been with us
for much longer than you might imagine
thank you to give you an idea the first
agricultural Futures Market was
registered in the United States in 1848
in the Chicago Board of Trade but it was
not until the 1960s and 1970s that we
could speak of a truly Global and
totally open market in which to buy and
sell agricultural products as production
could be sold in advance investment in
the sector increased an agricultural
exports soared
[Music]
and so a new Global Market was born
thanks to it developing countries that
find it more difficult to produce their
own food we're able to access a lot of
new much cheaper food in other words the
countries of sub-Saharan Africa that
could not get on board with the Green
Revolution were able to make up for
their production shortages by buying on
the international market and that
contributed decisively to reducing
famines this does not mean however that
they have not disappeared for example
right now there is the dramatic famine
that Somalia is going through as a
result of a severe ongoing drought which
has already claimed more than 43 000
lives on the other hand the dependents
of these countries on wheat Imports also
makes them more vulnerable to
International Market fluctuations we saw
this in the 2008 financial crisis which
led to a food crisis and we saw again in
the 2020 with the covid-19 crisis and
the collapse of Supply chains but now
the situation is even more dramatic take
a look at the countries which are the
world's leading grain exporters
exactly visual quality viewers Russia is
the world's largest grain exporter and
Ukraine the fifth largest and we are not
only talking about grains they are also
huge exporters of many other products
take the case of sunflower oil Ukraine
has a 46 world market share of this
staple before the war their black soils
very rich in nutrients along with reform
since the fall of the Soviet Union have
led the two countries to increase their
agricultural production to the point of
becoming the granaries of a large part
of Europe and the rest of the world
without going any further countries such
as Benin Tanzania and Congo import more
than 70 percent of their grain from
Russia precisely for this reason the
all-out war that is now pitting Russia
against Ukraine has set off all the
alarm Bells prices have skyrocketed and
food insecurity has once again become a
Hot Topic the question then is what is
being done to avoid another humanitarian
catastrophe in sub-Saharan Africa how is
an attempt being made to tame prices
well let's find out
[Music]
and turkey what's it doing here
we have already told you that Ukraine
was and still is one of the largest
green producers in the world indeed 72
percent of its entire rural population
Works in agriculture but the war has
been devastating for this sector between
shelling forced conscription and
Russia's Naval dominance in the Black
Sea production costs have gone through
the roof in addition it is estimated
that 25 of all Ukrainian households
living on agriculture have suspended
their activities however it is not only
Ukraine that has problems Russia is not
spared either true Western countries did
not impose sanctions against its
agricultural sector and in principle
they should have a much easier time
exporting to the rest of the world since
they dominate the Black Sea however the
sanctions are affecting them indirectly
being excluded from International
Payment Systems having their Logistics
sanctions and insurers refusing to work
with Russian cargos their agricultural
sector is suffering like the Ukrainian
one surely now you can better understand
a graph like this one so in case you're
wondering that's why bread and baked
goods were suddenly more expensive when
you went to the bakery or to the
supermarket obviously it's not just
about bread it's also about the bulk of
the food basket and of course what may
be an uncomfortable price increase in
Europe or the United States can mean the
difference between eating or Starving in
regions like sub-Saharan Africa and so
the international communities began to
call for changes to avoid a food
catastrophe and you know what this is
when our old friend turkey enters the
picture
[Music]
turkey's rule in this war between
Ukraine and Russia has been ambivalent
to say the least it has not sanctioned
Russia but neither has it supported as
it is a member of NATO turkey's rule in
this war has been ambivalent to say the
least it has not sanctioned Russia but
neither has it supported it as it is a
member of NATO and the country even has
supplied weapons to the Ukrainian Army
but beyond that what is certain is that
in general terms it is sought to play a
certain neutral role turkey has taken
advantage of this conflict to make a
move on the international chessboard and
try to win greater International
Sympathy by presenting itself as the
mediator between the two countries and
of course being on the Black Sea and in
control of the boss for a straight
turkey has played a key role in trying
to restore grain exports from the Black
Sea in fact together with the United
Nations it has been the Forerunner of a
crucial initiative to reduce World grain
prices the Black Sea grain initiative
and what does this initiative consist of
well very simply Russia does not bomb
Ukrainian ships carrying grain from the
Black Sea Ukraine enables three ports to
carry out its exports Odessa cornomorsk
and unity and turkey checks all vessels
and cargos in Istanbul when Ukrainian
ships enter and leave to prevent them
from for example carrying weapons sounds
good doesn't it well you have to admit
that the initiative has been pretty
successful
[Music]
as you can see both wheat and corn
prices have been falling since the
initiative was signed however there have
been moments of great uncertainty
because at times Russia has given the
impression that it wants to break this
agreement this has caused prices to
rebound every now and then and the fact
is that Moscow is playing with this
initiative they are trying to use it to
get some sanctions eased for example
when Putin signed his participation in
July 2022 he did so for four months and
in November when he renewed it he did
the same because recently on the 18th of
March this year when he had to renew it
he did so for only 60 days why because
he wants to tighten the screws on
Western countries and not only that
Russia wants to exploit this position
intensively just look at this if we
finally decide not to extend this
agreement within 60 days we are ready to
supply from Russia free of charge to
these countries all the volumes sent
during the last time to the African
countries in special need V Putin March
2023. we can't be sure that this is
going to be the case until Russia
decides to withdraw from the initiative
if it does pull out but giving something
away for free I don't know that doesn't
seem very Russian to me they always want
something in return
[Music]
we have already told you about how
Russian strategy in Africa and how the
Russian mercenary group of Wagner
closely linked to the Kremlin does not
provide its services altruistically gold
always comes first but even if it were
willing to do so it would be very
difficult if not impossible to replace
Ukrainian production this is why this
initiative is crucial for all parties
not only to lower prices on the
international markets but also to avoid
a new food catastrophe in the most
vulnerable regions as is precisely the
case in sub-Saharan Africa the problem
is that having Russia playing with this
deadline for extending its participation
not only generates great uncertainty in
the markets but also in the daily lives
of hundreds of millions of people at the
moment these are the expectations for
2023 and a market that is already very
pressured the world cereal Harvest will
fall by 2.2 percent in the
2022-2023 campaign according to the US
so hold on it's going to be a bumpy road
ahead but at this point the questions
are over to you do you think Russia will
break its participation in the green
initiative will we see another made food
crisis again what Solutions do you think
could be viable for alleviating
situation you can leave me your answer
in the comments below as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week subscribe
to this Channel and hit the little bell
button down there so you don't miss any
of our updates if you enjoyed this video
like it so we know all the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]